what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
John how are you I'm great how are you
sir good I'm looking forward to this if
you guys didn't catch our reaction to
the first episode that is up here on the
channel uh we loved it because uh I just
keep saying it was refreshing it was so
good such a good first episode my god
did not expect to have so much to say
yeah that was so it was so good anyway
we're gonna watch episode two right now
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified
when a reaction for the third episode
and uh full interaction watch alongs
where you single put your own copy for
Andor available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page additionally we
cover several shows we're the same tier
reaction highlights watch songs uh
included for shows that we cover
exclusively over there and team of
prepper thank you for helping us down
these highlights let's get to it
once again
[Music]
wow
that is striking
that big old saw
Guerrera ah it'll be here at some point
[Music]
[Music]
hey I got some money why don't we do
something fun tomorrow
's upline lock up the back I'll take
care of all this
thank you you're not edgy enough for her
who will snooze
about what that you were born in qunari
you don't want to hear what happened
we'll get to that but who knows who have
we told I don't know I we have always
said first every doc I've ever submitted
has always said you were born on Fest
have you ever said anything other than
the best officially no I don't think so
but people yes
how many I don't know it's not something
I've been keeping track of what everyone
I've told is dead
and who told these Primo Bastards about
Canary that wouldn't be me mix is
looking for you what well why would you
do that when just now tell me
forget that she's still in the yard what
dude
you're shaking me down
I wasn't looking for a fight listen
forget what I said this morning I'll
tell you the piece well how stressed out
desperate
[Laughter]
it's too late to call him off he'll be
here in the morning
oh no oh God you're the worst are you
the main villain of the show
so he knows he's from canary
perhaps
[Music]
or maybe put together the because she
was looking at that and then immediately
talking to him
he's beautiful
I must have him
oh are you all right
I'll know
[Music]
foreign
drama
intimate Star Wars story I love it
I thought of anything less than full
engagement on a case like this
uncomfortable song Dead election of Duty
at the minimum
I've seen it so
have measures
to take it slow to wait and see
it's a plague on discipline I've been
saying all along we need a stronger hand
with these Affiliated planets corporate
tactical forces are the Empire's first
line of defense and the best way to keep
the blade sharp is to use it
so
I don't know about this guy keep an eye
on that one yeah he would harm people
pray
so nervous about that flashback what
happened yeah this is something horrible
the weights
I like that his walking stick looks like
a replica lightsaber right yeah
just about to put it on
Star Wars coffee
when you open up the yard for me this
morning
uh sure
dang Star Wars intimacy what's up this
morning
just got a few errands to run
won't be long
it really feels like get a little guilty
about it too you have credits for Marva
you need to to tell me where you're
hiding them because we don't want
someone else to find marva's credits do
we
I agree
you should stay
you need to get back she's gonna wonder
where you are come on
go
such an endearing Droid
[Music]
look at his skin man yeah
[Music]
[Music]
God damn 50 Cent go down
[Music]
kill this kid I'm the second episode
what's going on here
Jesus I'm looking up Canary Canary mid
Rim abandoned after Imperial mining
disaster abandoned and considered toxic
Imperial prohibition
no no there's no reward
corporate enforcement are looking for
someone you know anybody from Canary
what can I do for you
what would we be picking up give me the
price for not knowing
wait
explosive I know does it talk give me a
number Sam
900. a real number you want immediacy
and discretion that's an expensive combo
I got 500. well you should plan more
carefully okay let's split the
difference it's your choice you want to
go today and have me keep my mouth shut
sevens my floor okay if it's seven you
better be ready in an hour
if the engine running
would you let it go
Cassian Andor not a recent image but the
best we've got he may not appear to be a
formidable opponent
but two of our men are dead having made
that mistake
oh
we will have the element of surprise
but there should be no Illusions as to
the risks involved
and maybe some local residents who are
lesson enthused with that presence you
may remind them that there's a
territorial Forum once a month where
they are free to make official
complaints
leave it in the comment box oh yes sir
crazy
he's trying to do the right thing to
realize did what he had to do there
comes a time when the
the risk of doing nothing becomes the
greatest risk of all one of those
decisive moments and I
can't imagine a
team I'd rather share it with than all
of you there's no room for doubt on the
path to
success
best of luck to us all
good job
what what a contrast
[Applause]
please clap me I'm in propulsion we do
add-ons and boosters
oh nice
you know what they say if you can't find
it here it's not worth finding
it
[Music]
works like a real flight it is
slept all right so cool
[Music]
[Music]
towns
damn
Toby Haynes
Toby Haynes man oh man Toblerone
wow
good show man
absolutely
I feel like we've said we're out of [ __ ]
morbius I think she didn't think she saw
it it's more of a time she's good at
Morpheus
I've been trying to place it yeah yeah
that's the first question we'll ask her
is it morbin time and then she'll have
the same answer what is that what are
you talking about
oh my God
we gotta get her to stay just once can
you say this for our first oh National
Theater I got a fool I was like it is
National Treasure no he's not uh Justin
bartha or whatever that's who that is
yeah I don't think I've ever seen any of
this guy's work yeah he just looks like
he's a that guy he has that face yeah
an old white male face
um anyway
yeah this is uh fascinating stuff so
it's not his actual Mom right who's she
I get the sense that yeah it's it's
probably like once he was displaced when
yeah yeah it's like whoever took him in
after that she's doing a great job too
like like they they have that one scene
together but even the times where you
just cut to her and it's mostly just
physical performance like she's got so
much presence too
you see like there are shows I've I
watch
um
on my own time that I I just I don't
bother to do reactions to that I love
like better call Saul's my favorite show
of the year so far
and I'm normally just really quiet he's
a slow burn slow break character trauma
yeah I'm supposed to draw you in
Westworld same same thing obviously
bigger and cooler heavy because it's
Westworld but I have the same kind of
thing and then I find myself with this
doing that and I'm like
oh yeah I should probably let let people
know like how I'm sort of feeling right
now
because yeah
truly truly a gripping Slow Burn show is
like oh yeah yeah big part all right
what I always tell people is whenever if
they're new to filming with us it's like
whatever you're feeling internally just
you know let it show uh let this be the
platform where you get to express
yourself and express what you're feeling
internally literally just express it
and I find myself just so encrypted that
I'm like oh really oh yeah yeah it's
probably like say something
oh wait snap out of it
you're on camera bud this is the show
yeah this is this is great this I'm I'm
so into it it is like the kind of show I
I just watch on my own time and just
sort of absorb myself into of because I
like this kind of sci-fi dread of
something that just feels like it's it's
it's not like Star Wars is oh you know
what it is the best way I can describe
how I've been experiencing this show so
far Star Wars has always felt like a
galaxy far far away this does not feel
that far away no this feels like the
future we could possibly get to one day
yeah yeah while still maintaining those
trappings of yeah feeling like the
histories of a lost time or something
like that but yeah way less distant
somehow yeah yeah I guess yeah it's like
it's just as Fantastical and it has all
that flourish of set design and costume
design all that sort of stuff but yeah
it feels much closer thematically and
emotionally to home aesthetically closer
to home in a lot of ways too because I
think the characters are so because even
like the
obsessed boyfriend or whatever the hell
this guy is um
even their relationship something like
that which I thought this guy was gonna
be uh here we go pompous annoying nosy
[ __ ] who she can't tell is a freaking
douchebag
look right in front of you yeah yeah
um I thought that but even him you could
tell he's in conflict over the decision
he's made oh yeah when she comes to the
door it's such a great moment and when
they part too because you could tell
they're both not saying how they're
feeling and and yeah with him yeah it's
like as much as that moment passes where
he's like oh yeah I'm turning it in or
I'm taking a a move on this you know
once he sees her you can it's it's so
wonderfully acted because yeah like his
demeanor changes and you can tell like
he he's just jealous in in a way and
feels inadequate and feels overlooked
and he just has eyes for her I mean even
if we're wrong about that that's part of
the greatness of I think the visual
language of the directing is
you can interpret it you know because
when he is just watching her in the
morning he's like am I I he obviously
really has feelings for this woman
yet he's he's uh you could tell he's um
feels bad about the decision because
this this is someone and or he doesn't
care about but she cares about it and he
cares about her yeah yeah and and I like
that they're actually again like I've
talked about in the last episode they
paint that gray quality with the care
like this I heard about it and then
promotions leading up to it like yeah
you know a lot of this feels like really
beaut and Care everything's character
driven in this show and I feel like I've
heard that so many times and it's just
not doesn't feel that way yeah and I'm
like the show is this show is so
character driven in the subtlest ways
even you know the the surrogate mother
I'm assuming surrogate mother
um what is that actress's name yeah
she's in the Harry Potter yeah she's
been in touch but tons of British
everything like I love the real world
sternness of their conversation and how
he's trying to like what I'm loving
about what cat what Diego Luna is doing
in every scene is you could always feel
his prior moment before entering the
scene he's in yeah yeah
[ __ ] dealing with this hey how's it
going
um
I'm in a good mood and I'm only honest
with my robot when he pissed me off
because I'm trying to get [ __ ] done you
know yeah no it's so real and it's and
it's perfectly lived in for for this out
out of the box Universe you know like
it's as Fantastical as it is it is so
very very identifiable in in the
demeanors of everybody and and she's
credited as Marva and Doris so he must
have taken on her name I would guess but
there's so much going on yeah so much
going on underneath oh so it must be I
don't know maybe they are there's so
much always going on underneath the
surface of these characters like Cassian
like he enters that bar when he when he
before
um
you know we have their names here don't
we yeah God damn it Bix before before
Bix uh confronts him about uh what's
important up I can put out by corporate
you you
again he walks in he's like I'm over
here before I just love how you can feel
all that stress underneath her when he's
talking to that Sam character about
getting that uh ship
and and how he how he chooses to like
one thing I hate and one of the the most
cliche things I hate in all movies and
shows is when a character is obviously
lying or obviously covering up yes you
know and and the way they chose to
Capture Moments where he's listening you
could tell they're talking about
um Canary and but then when he responds
like the responses he gives just feels
so human is so real in the cover-up of
how he goes about handling it and you
can still feel like the the feelings of
worrying being caught in fear but also
the triggers of his like the past that's
been buried oh yeah coming up to get
like to haunt him and he's like he's a
fugitive right now when he's trying to
just get out of there without letting on
that he's like anxious and like
completely on edge about this whole
thing as you can see him in that moment
be like sort of caught off guard but
yeah he like Chuckles and he's like what
is that I've never heard of that and
it's so like if you know what's going on
under this the surface you can see what
he's doing but if you it's believable
enough and subtle enough that yeah if
this character doesn't know he's just
like yeah he hadn't heard a video what
do you expect I like the stress and I
like the combination of like stress and
Care like with uh Marva and or that that
first scene they have together how
you know you could just tell that that
tension because so many characters are
so disapproving of Cassie and Andor
um you know and she obviously loves him
and wants to look out for him but it's
like when he walks through that door you
just feel the history again that's
something that I keep saying with this
is the history with these characters you
can feel all that history of God damn it
but then the Fawn memory is when they're
picking up when she walks into his room
to you know what looks like to scold him
and then it's caught off guard by
Reminiscing on items yeah
um uh not corellia um corellias the
other character yeah
Canary yeah it really is Han Solo
um so yeah when it when they go when she
picks up those items like it's it it's
like a character study but it doesn't
ever feel like it slows down to be a
character study well no it's not that
thing of yeah you like
uh going into say Obi-Wan you expected
like oh this is going to be a character
this is what I wanted Obi-Wan to do it
exactly is and the thing is Obi-Wan part
of the frustrating thing is it would
occasionally take moments to have
character-driven scenes that were very
effective but this feels like character
driven just is the mode that it existed
remix
which that's the name I recognize too
from I I don't know if that's like a big
no this is one of those shows where I'm
like who's who's this who is everybody
yeah
yeah like there's just yeah it's that
it's like those again those scenes with
Marva like you cut back to her a couple
times you know and and they could feel
in a show that wasn't character as
character driven as this is those would
feel random and sort of like oh why do
we cut back to her but like even in the
way they're paced in you can tell that
they're deliberate and they're going to
be revealing and they also just I don't
know there's something about the way
they've hewned the again the acting the
writing all the designs and everything
to a point where yeah even in a little
quiet scene that's just a little
vignette on its own you're still drawn
in and you're still kind of fascinated
by everything and I mean you know it's a
it's a testament to the show's Goodwill
it's got to sustain this over 12
episodes but thus far it just feels like
the sensibility it's coming from is a
thoughtful one and I love too the
journey so far from
uh what is his name the Kyle solar
character the guy who's heading up this
investigation of Cassie and Andor and
who is like so in over his head in the
way in the first episode you watch as uh
Cyril yeah you you watch in the first
episode as like he's yeah like you said
he's just trying to kind of do the right
thing and not Overlook a real situation
that should you know be explored and
have its consequences and yeah you've
got that like overhead guy in the first
episode who's just like really business
as usual and so dismissive and now he's
got this other guy who is like so
gung-ho and so has such Gusto about just
like iron fisting like like you know
kind of really cracking down I feel like
it's gonna slowly become like a parallel
for police brutality in a way I feel
like it could yeah it's like this guy
who just wants to to see Justice done
and to see something not swept under the
rug and who might find himself in a
situation where it's like Whoa We Are
proceeding with way too much yeah like
way too much uh Firepower or way too
much aggression at the outset because
yeah that's who it seems like the guy
who's the the one who's like overly
encouraged you know really supportive
and those are always really scary
characters I feel like because it's like
the way he's a soldier that guy yeah and
the way you know it's like Cyril's
speech is so awkward and so does not
land and it's him he's the one guy who
comes up and he's like no you did a
great job great words you know like and
you could tell that that's the guy who
like is vehemently passionately in your
corner now but you deviate you get out
of his good grace at any point and I bet
that'll be a big nightmare of a
situation and so it's like even though
they are technically on the same side
and even though they are both opposition
to and or it's like I feel like things
are going to get worse and this guy's
gonna get in over his head and maybe
that could put them on a similar path
ultimately you know
yeah it's really impressive yeah and
with the Bix character I
I'm so I we don't really know much about
who she is but she's so good to like I
like watching her yeah like I want to
know more about oh who she is and you
get that impression that because she's
she's obviously unlike and or respected
like people have respect for her yeah
and I like that the relationship they
draw with her and Andor while there's
that jealousy with the one guy it seems
like they're actually just real like
just friends you know like they're not I
don't get the Romantic inkling with at
least I don't pick up on that Vibe other
than the fact they're both attractive
human beings I I don't pick up on the
vibe that they are even the way he
teases her about who in the first
episode about it you know them about who
she's banging she's not he he doesn't
there was no hint in that scene of
jealousy or something like that yeah and
you get the impression that she's
someone who's like a support for and or
and and a sympathetic support for Andor
like when everyone's always looked down
on him she's always trying to help him
out she seems like a real friend even if
they don't always get along and I don't
I don't like the show hasn't told us
that but that's part of the strength of
the show is I that seems that's the vibe
he getting yeah well and hats off to her
because especially in the day and age we
live in now I feel like there it could
have been a version of this where you
know you it would have been maybe hard
to sell but like that first scene you
meet her in the first episode when she's
working on those engines
and you meet her in her element I'm like
I totally believe that this is this
character's like you know like very uh
conventionally pretty attractive actress
stepping into this kind of role can
sometimes be especially in this universe
for some people a tall order but again
it's a testament to just good
storytelling and good character work and
a good actor that yeah like she a
thousand percent feels natural in kind
of every situation thus far that they
have drawn around and I love that you
get what to me seems like one of the
first sort of instances of like just
like an intimate relationship like she
when when it's the morning after and
she's like sitting on the bed and
getting dressed in something like that
it's it's such a simple little thing and
it's such a simple detail and it
contributes to the rest of the scene but
it's stuff like that where I'm like I'm
not used to being the in this
setting in flavor in a Star Wars show
and it's that stuff that really draws
you in I think to these characters that
much more and makes the makes it work
despite not having the info dumps worth
of backstory yet you know what about
when Rey took off her bikini at the pool
to distract the guards
yeah yeah totally and they cluck their
heads together
and then one fell in the pool doing The
Wilhelm scream yeah yeah yeah totally
the rose Tico does the bend and snap to
get Finn to stop Flags
yeah totally
so much sex appeal across the Star Wars
fridge yeah I mean first you got to be a
doctor alongside Michael morbius we'll
eventually see monmouth's Origins as a
stripper
all right guys well we got another one
to go through but thank you for being
here uh
Everett pixel Mike Baker we have looked
up your name on Urban Dictionary that
way John doesn't do another pixel
related shout out
here we go
he's the kind of guy he'll say no to and
regret it oh no and yet for some reason
he's to one who sticks around long
enough until you're ready for him
interesting kind of like accepting
pixels into your heart he's kind
thoughtful and compassionate with the
people he's close to but everyone else
is a total ass those are Mighty virtues
he's shy when you first meet him and
Reserve sometimes when he opens up to
you that's how you know you're special
oh valid dating people
he's a best friend and a boyfriend all
rolled into one friend that is
incredible right babe that's you've
always I've always want my lover to feel
like call me back he's hilarious and
loves puns almost as much as he loves
hydration he might have actually really
enjoyed all those pixel shout outs
you've done oh no while drinking water
hey well I'm wet right now just thinking
about it don't let him go because he's
worth keeping around well you better not
leave the only way we're letting you go
is if you choose to leave but by that
point I hope you open up to us long
enough yeah you'll stick around it's in
the definition
Everett I love you we should have done a
pixel related shout outs okay because
this
is too accurate of a definition of who
you are my friend
[Music]